una vasectomía es un método permanente
de control de la natalidad para los
hombres en el que el cirujano realiza la
sección y ligadura de una parte del
tracto reproductivo masculino a fin de
evitar que el esperma salga del cuerpo
del hombre durante la eyaculación
el sistema reproductivo del hombre
incluye los testículos dos estructuras
ovaladas en donde el esperma las células
reproductivas del hombre se produce cada
testículo se conecta con los conductos
deferentes tubos que llevan esperma a la
uretra un canal en el pene que
transporta la orina y el esperma durante
la eyaculación cada conducto deferente
impulsa esperma a través de las
vesículas seminales y la glándula
prostática estructuras que proporcionan
líquido nutritivo y transporte para el
esperma ahora llamado semen esta
combinación de esperma y sustancias
fluidas continúa su trayecto a través de
la uretra y es expulsada por el pene
durante las relaciones sexuales el semen
pasa el sistema reproductivo femenino en
donde la esperma puede encontrar y
fertilizar un óvulo si no desea
embarazar a una mujer puede elegir un
método de control de la natalidad de una
de las varias categorías abstinencia
para evitar completamente el embarazo al
no tener relaciones sexuales
contracepción para evitar temporalmente
el embarazo a través del uso de diversos
métodos durante las relaciones sexuales
o esterilización para evitar
permanentemente el embarazo a través de
un procedimiento médico la vasectomía es
una forma de esterilización antes de
iniciar el procedimiento se le
administrara en inyecciones de anestesia
local para adormecer el área en una
vasectomía convencional se usa un
bisturí para realizar una incisión
pequeña en un lado de su escroto el saco
de piel delgada que alberga los
testículos
su médico localizar a el conducto
deferente y lo levantará a través de la
incisión en este momento posiblemente
tendrá una sensación de tirantez se
cortará el conducto deferente y se
retirará una pequeña parte luego los
extremos del conducto deferente cortados
recientemente se atarán ligarán con
clips quirúrgicos o se caracterizarán el
conducto deferente será colocado de
regreso en el escroto y se suturar a
se repetirán los mismos pasos en el otro
lado del escroto este procedimiento
tarda cerca de 30 minutos en el método
en el que no se usa bisturí su médico
usará una pinza de anillo especial para
sujetar y exponer los conductos
deferentes a partir de este momento en
adelante el procedimiento es el mismo
que en el de la vasectomía convencional
este método está normalmente asociado
con una cicatrización más rápida y menos
complicaciones y es tan eficaz como el
método convencional
inmediatamente después de cualquiera de
los procedimientos se le pedirá que
descanse en el consultorio del médico
por un corto tiempo las incisiones
cicatrizarán en pocos días dejando una
pequeña o ninguna cicatriz después del
procedimiento será necesario que limite
su actividad física por uno o dos días
no se podrá bañar por 24 horas será
necesario que evite levantar objetos
pesados realizar labores arduas o
ejercitarse demasiado por cinco o siete
días será necesario que evite tener
actividad sexual por 7 días